it was just one missile but it damaged
four medical buildings bashtanka
hospital was hit early evening on
tuesday a surgery was in progress and a
woman was giving birth
luckily children had been moved from the
pediatric center to a safer place
depressingly ukraine's medical staff
know their buildings are being targeted
[Music]
medical kit is destroyed even internal
door frames displaced every window
shattered
hospital which served a community of 140
000 people is now unworkable
patients moved elsewhere
the russians have renamed their invasion
operation defend donbass but it's really
hard to understand why that would
require the bombing of a hospital
three hundred miles away from the region
the continued shelling in the province
of mikolav speaks of something beyond
vladimir putin's stated intentions
families are also fleeing from russian
occupied curson where the kremlin is
threatening a referendum to turn it into
an independent republic
this couple has just escaped the region
that would be a sinister twist so far
bash tanker has held back the russian
advance but the town is scarred by war
and so to its people
valentina says her family in russia
thinks she's a nazi hmm
to a dwindling market
foreign
high street is a parade of shops gutted
by fire the pharmacy the beauty salon
but even this doesn't convey how ugly
this war has become
jason farrell sky news bash tanker